إذا كنت تشاهد الأخبار، يا إلهي، يا إلهي،
أحيانًا يجعلك ترغب في التقيؤ،
تخيل كيف يكون الشعور بالتقيؤ
أثناء نشر الأخبار أو على الأقل
الطقس كريه الرائحة، نعم، الهواء
منعش جدًا هنا هذا الصباح يا كارل،
لا أستطيع أن أؤكد يا إلهي.  أنا لدينا
بعض الماشية التي نتعامل معها
جيدًا، لدي حالة من الكمامات التي
تحدث هنا ولكن رائحة
الأبقار التي اختلط بها في الفناء، اجعله في
هذا فقط يستمر في الالتفاف علي
وأنا لست كذلك  بالتأكيد ما أشعر به حيال ذلك،
تيم ديفيز يقوم بمقاطع الطقس
لتسع شبكات، برنامج اليوم في أستراليا،
غالبًا ما يقوم بالكمامات ولكن هذا كان
إسكاتًا فعليًا على الهواء مباشرة وهو يضحك يا إلهي، لقد
تعاملت شخصيًا مع
الكثير من الماشية على مدار مسيرتي
المهنية بدءًا من الخنازير  مثل صديقي
هنا
لكنهم لم يثيروا ردة فعل هفوة أبدًا
في الاستوديو، غنى أحد المذيعين
تمجيد روث البقر وفركه
وفركه على بشرتك، تيمي،
إنه جميل أن هذه الأشياء لم يكن تيم
متسكعًا، لقد ذهب جندي
يعتذر عنه  المزارع، أنا آسف، أنا شديد الأسف، أنا شخص
ماهر في المدينة، أتقن الإسكات حتى تعود الأبقار إلى المنزل.
CNN، تلقيت حالة من الكمامات التي تحدث
هنا من نيويورك مباشرة في
التوقعات إذا كان هذا مناسبًا للجميع